the Joe Rogan experience hey man we
started this podcast off talking
off the record and I thought it was
probably good for everybody here like
when I'm so happy you're not fighting
you know and what we're saying is I know
that I was a dick to you to get you to
stop doing it but I felt I felt like
there was almost no other way that you
were gonna let like I felt scared I've
seen too many people that are just
there's this there's a moment where it
changes where they stop being that
person and they keep fighting and you
see it you see the deterioration and no
one steps in and no one stops them and
then that Todd you'll talk to him alone
man maybe you run into him in Vegas
maybe you both have a couple of drinks
you see each other at the bar and you're
like hey how's things and you have these
conversations and then the reality sets
in things are not good for a lot of
these guys a lot of these guys that have
taken punishment for too long there's no
bringing them back man they get to this
spot where you know everyone knows
there's something wrong and no one says
anything to him and I was real scared
that that was gonna happen to you I was
real scared you know
like I didn't anticipate when we did
that crazy podcast that wound up being
you know this like intervention I didn't
even know I was gonna do it but while
was happening I was like I just you got
to stop that's all I was thinking is you
gotta get out I was a little high yeah I
found I don't even remember we were
drinking but we probably were but I
remember that being so sensitive to it
like there's something has to be done
like now you kind of you you had so many
other possibilities that there's if like
most guys that are all in on fighting
they don't have anything on the side
like there's almost nothing else there
there's almost just fighting and maybe a
family right but you were you were
starting to flourish you're hilarious on
podcast what you know that can go away
man guys become shells and man I see it
right no now that you're out you see it
right
yeah I think thank god or whoever's up
there man for you and bryan callen thank
[ __ ] i know it came out Dickie I know
it did and I know I know I apologize
then and I apologize now but I think
that's the only way you could do it I
don't know you weren't gonna listen I
knew you know you had this pride like
you were like we were talking about
before the show you were a top ten
professional heavyweight in the biggest
organization in the world that's a
that's a identity thing to men that like
the you people get strapped into that
identity that's one of the harder things
about fighters is when you quit you you
have to find meaning in your life like
what did what are you good at now but
dude for me I know I never did anything
professionally but it was the formative
stages of my life where the only thing
that gave me any feelings of good was
martial arts you feel like a loser the
only thing the only thing everything
else I felt even the I was kind of good
at drawing but even then I was like my
drawing teacher didn't like me I had
friends that I was close with in the
class we all drew and we liked our stuff
but man I felt like a [ __ ] loser
except for martial arts so when I quit
and then I'm just doing comedy and I
suck at comedy I was eating [ __ ] and I
was like what am i quitting for like I'm
quitting something that I was good at to
be something that I suck at that I maybe
think I have this pipe dream that I
could eventually making a living out of
I remember that feeling of not having an
identity and obviously when you're 21 no
one has an identity anyway you're always
so [ __ ] confusion had you trying to
figure it out I was super fortunate
where I was surrounded by guys like you
Cal and Bert Tom and it's just like
where that I want to be in that party I
was I was so fortunate I get the stars
aligned for me where I was at this party
over here and guys were getting CT and
you know you're fighting and it's a
[ __ ] grind and then you guys were
over here I'm like well I want to be one
of them I'm good man I'm good I want to
do that yeah and I think it took that
bridging that gap you and to be honest I
think that would that's the only way
that you could have done it because they
the ego that I had at the time
especially fighting men begin to that
level it was like that ego is insane the
narcissist and the the dream of I can be
Cain
Steve pay these guys and I think the
only way that I could have bridge that
gap is by you going so hard in the paint
dude I was so scared biting god I'm so
scared they were gonna fight you with in
Ghana or someone like that you know I
mean I was so scared you were gonna get
murked by some some when you weren't all
in anymore you know those big [ __ ]
when you watch like when when Francis
merked over him with that left uppercut
Jesus Christ like if that was you know
and I was calling that fight man it
would be an I love Alistair he's a great
guy I have a deep appreciation for him
as a fighter huh I mean I'm yeah and my
feeling was when he came over his k1
grand prix champion like this is the
most celebrated striker we've ever had
and in my main you saw it in his fight
with brock lesnar phenomen dude he
people and got one of the things that
makes that Francis ko so [ __ ] crazy
insane I mean this he did the same thing
did you need dos Santos remember Overeem
did it yep he hit him with a beautiful
left hook very similar punch super
worried about that with you man but but
I also I also think too for me it was
like this quick ascension into into this
UFC and I'm and I'm fighting his top 10
top 15 guys I'm in this I'm in this
world but it's like I was almost like a
cheat code because I was really athletic
I was really really athletic with my
background so I got I passed a lot of
guys fast my athleticism but then you
get to a certain point where you're
fighting these vets where they've they
fought big powerful athletic guys before
but then it comes down to experience and
technique and that's always always gonna
win nine times out then that's always
gonna win
[Applause]